Theo thông tin từ lúc quân hành Quốc, môi mô trọng gá tại khu vực điểm giá đã được tạm thời khuối phục,
với tầm ngăn sách người chiến phải sống sống kỳ quan, tương đương mề bốn phải năm triệu đồ lầm miế.
Bây tay thế, bao giờ từ tháng 2 năm mai nghìn không trả mai miter,
và kéo dài đến tháng năm mai nghìn không tròa mấy năm, nhằm tăng cường nó hưởng giám sát,
chú bất cảnh tình dình án ninh khu vực giá tăng căng thẳng,
các công trình hiện tại chủ yếu bao gồm tương trắng và công tình ơn, làm nơi chủ đắm cho mình sĩ.
Đồng thái này, giễn ra sau khi chủ tiến đơn phương quy bỏ thuật quân sự,
này mình chỉ nơi chỉ nha mai nghìn không trả mấy tảm,
bánh kiện tương đánh sấu bức tế lớn chung lỗ lực dạm căn thẳng quân sự liên châu,
kể từ đó bình nhận mắt đầu tái lập các trạm gá từ lịt phá bỏ,
khiến hành Quốc đưa ra phản nữ tương nữ,
giữa qua sát tại suen nhận định, với khuối phục chỉ dựng hấm mức tạm thời,
săm có thể mở giọc thành kế hoạch dài hạn, nếu tình hình không cả thiệt.
Tuy nhiên, tương lai của các trạm gác bánh phụ thuật vào chính sách nước ngoại,
của chính phụ hành Quốc nghiệp kỳ tới.
Nếu tòo tòo tòo nghe mình chỉ nơi chỉ nơi khói phục theo cám kết trình cử của tầm khoảng lịch trình m樣,
toàn bộ quá sình có thể bị đing trị.